hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
approaches to valuing an understanding
friendship that Cicero discusses in his
work on friendship and which he
considers to be misguided for a variety
of reasons is thinking that we can't
have deep intimate abiding friendships
if we really want to have freedom in our
life we don't want to get too attached
people often say I don't want to lend my
heart to somebody if it might you know
lead to my feeling bad or even feeling
worried about things and and he
considers a number of interesting cases
and situations and provides arguments
for for why it is that we shouldn't take
that point of view we should hold
ourselves ready to become friends at
least friends with the right sorts of
people not just anybody but people who
have the potential for being genuine
friends people who we can see are if not
perfectly virtuous at least on the way
towards that state and he criticizes
these Greek sages or wise people and I
should
should mention here that Cicero himself
is a Roman and part of his larger
project was to take the the wisdom the
philosophy the ideas from greece that
people were studying in greek and put
them into a latin idiom to show not only
that the latin tongue could actually
function as a vehicle for thought but
also that you could you could do these
sorts of things pretty much anywhere you
didn't have to be in greece thinking in
in their modes and so criticizing these
greek sages is a way of saying you know
actually maybe these these Greeks didn't
get everything right when it comes to
friendship and he says that you know
some of the things that they say seem
seem quite walk base to me he says these
are considered sages in Greece and
they've approved certain views which in
my opinion are astonishing so what are
these sorts of views there's several of
them one is that we should avoid having
too much intimacy too much attachment
too much connection within the scope of
our friendships why well there's there's
really two main reasons that he ad
deuces and both of these have to do with
what we can call effective 'ti now
friendship itself is a pleasant thing
you know when we're all getting along
but it also brings other feelings
doesn't it so he talks about care or
worry or another way of translating it
is anxiety we we worry about what other
people are doing what's going to happen
to them and so he says that it we don't
want it to be necessary for one person
to be full of anxiety or care silica
Theo silica Tim for many people for a
multitude parole
pluribus in in this so if we could say
that we have enough things to worry
about for ourselves we don't need to
worry or be concerned with what what's
happening to other people we're better
off if we if we don't do that we're free
we're free of care in that case the
other thing that he talks about is being
bothered being put out by having to you
know be involved with other people's
affairs or business he says each one of
us has business of his own and nothing
to spare it's annoying to be too much
involved in the affairs of other people
and so the suggestion here is well if
you know you don't want to have a
unpleasant life don't get too close to
anybody you can mean kind of friends you
can have acquaintances you can have
connections just you know make sure that
you don't let anyone completely inside
and and so the idea here he follows this
out and he says it's best to hold the
reins of friendship as loosely as
possible so that we may either draw them
up or slack in them at will now what are
the reins of friendship the idea here is
this like riding a horse the reins are
the thing that you use to control it
right the the attachment so there's kind
of a double metaphor going on here you
you want to lead you don't want to have
the reins too tight so that the horse is
is you know being rigid or anything now
you let them loose and then if you need
to tighten them up you tighten them up
and if you want to let them go
completely loose you do that and so the
idea is don't let your friends be too
close to you and don't get too close to
your friends and don't worry about them
very much because you know if you really
do need to worry about them then you can
tighten the reins or you might just let
them go and so your problems aren't my
problems and so he says that an
essential of a happy life is freedom
from care not having to worry about
everything there's in in Latin it's
securitas right and we're going to come
back to that in just a moment this idea
so he says the
Sol cannot enjoy it if one man is as it
were in travail for many people so
you've got your own stuff to take care
of just do that don't worry about
anybody else or if you do make sure that
you're not too worried and you can
always cut them loose if you need to so
Cicero doesn't think this is a good way
to behave he continues on and he talks
about some people having a view of
friendship now these are not necessarily
the sages this is a whole bunch of other
people who he says have kind of a a bad
view of friendship a low view of
friendship they view friendship as being
based on lack or need you are friends
with people because they supply what it
is that you're missing and we can think
of all sorts of examples of this right
you're friends with your neighbor
because he invites you to the good
parties and you like going to the
parties and drinking his beer and eating
his brats and all those other things and
so you stay friends with him even though
you really don't like the guy and maybe
you borrow his lawnmower every once in a
while hedge clippers or whatever else it
is that people do out in the suburbs
right or your friends it really lovers
with somebody because they can get you
off they can give you sexual pleasure
that you could possibly give yourself
something like that yourself but it's
better to do it with somebody else or
there's things that they can do that
that you can't really do by yourself
that's the only reason you're connected
with them and if they stop doing that
end of the relationship right or you're
friends with somebody because they give
you the answers to the test and and
Cicero goes on and says that vulnerable
people
given this point of view would be the
ones who would be in most need of
friendship those least endowed with
firmness of character and strength of
body and so they would seek its shelter
the poor more than the rich the
unfortunate more than those accounted
fortunate so what if you are one of the
people who's fortunate well you don't
need anybody that do you just stay by
yourself being self-sufficient or having
we use that word earlier so Caritas
right having security having being well
provided for means you don't have to
have any friends because what are they
gonna do they're just gonna come in you
don't need anything from them so why
would you want to have them around
they're just going to actually create
need and you know bother you by telling
you about their day and what's going on
and what they like to have and you know
get them out of here get rid of them
it's better to be totally on your own
because then you can be free so once the
delivery person has delivered your you
know stock of food and your game console
and your big-screen TV and hooked up
your cable and connected your internet
and done all the things get them the
hell out of there you don't need any of
those people around don't even bother
talking with them that's that's sort of
the advice here
Cicero thinks that that's not a good
idea and he says he's being facetious
here o noble philosophy they seem to
take the Sun out of the universe when
they deprive life of friendship that
which we have from the immortal gods no
better no more no more delightful boon
because what's really going on here he
says what value is there vaunted freedom
from care in appearance it's often an
alluring thing but in reality often to
be shunned so he says it's inconsistent
not to undertake any honorable business
or course of conduct or to lay it aside
when undertaken in order to avoid
anxiety so it's kind of ignoble if we
continually flee from trouble we must
also flee from virtue who necessarily
meets with some trouble in rejecting and
loathing things contrary to her self as
when kindness rejects ill-will and he
goes on and he says that if we want to
be good people we have to be engaged
with other people there's going to be
some other motives as well that he's
going to get to a bit later that have
more to do with pleasure he he then
brings up another interesting
here about virtue and he says if
distress of mind the Falls a wise man as
it certainly does unless we assume human
sympathy has been routed out of his
heart why should we remove friendship
entirely from our lives in order that we
may suffer no worries on it account on
its account when the soul is deprived of
now here is being translated as deprived
of emotion and the Latin simply says you
no mo - ah - Musa blot oh right but but
the movement of the mind that we're
seeing here is that of emotion right
when the soul is deprived of emotion
what difference is there I don't say
between a human being and beast of the
field but between even lower a human
being and a stick or a stone or any such
thing we become inhuman by depriving
ourselves by removing from ourselves the
the care the emotional connection with
other people we render ourselves less
human which for Cicero is not a good
thing we deprive ourselves with
something very good in the process and
he says that there's people who think
that if you're going to be virtuous if
you're going to be good morally good
then you have to be uncompromising a
real tough person he says some people
think that virtue is hard and unyielding
and as it were something made of iron
and Cicero says this is actually
misguided the person who conceives of
virtue in that way and thereby pushes
potential friends away or perhaps their
family members or work colleagues or
whoever it's going to be they're not
really virtuous why because virtue
itself becomes flexible and adaptable
within the scope of friendship which
implies you can't really be completely
virtuous unless you're actually within
relationships very interesting idea
there so he goes on and he says in many
relations of life virtue is pliable and
elastic so that it expands so to speak
with a friend's prosper
and contracts with his adversity and so
you know he says we shouldn't banish
friendship from life any more than we
should reject virtue because virtue
entails certain cares and annoyances we
should we should look for friendship
even if it does mean being bothered by
things so the sister was willing to
admit
yes friendship does involve care for
others
sometimes worries about others being
preoccupied with their stuff taking the
the phone call at night that keeps you
from being able to do whatever it is
that you want to do or wakes you up in
the middle of the night you know helping
people move prime example right for the
beer and the pizza that you're gonna get
afterwards these are important things
and they shouldn't lead us to devalue
friendship in the favor of being free
now he brings up the example of a guy
very famous legendary even in Greece
named Timon who was a renowned
misanthropic misanthrope is a person who
doesn't like other people who and I'll
say something more they actually hate
other people it comes from the word
measles which means hate right so they
hate other people for whatever reason
and he says that even if someone were of
nature so savage and fierce as to shun
and loathe the Society of human beings
even such a person could not refrain
from seeking out some person before whom
he might pour out the venom of his
embittered soul isn't that an
interesting idea he's not seeking out
anyone to like it enjoy him his time
with them he's not seeking them out
because he loves that Mark Harris or
though he just wants to [ __ ] about how
terrible life is and how awful other
people are haven't we seen people like
this I'm sure some of you have run
across a few I know I certainly have
there are only happy by being miserable
and they like to spread that misery
around you can't spread that misery
around with
being at least somewhat intimate with
other people I mean this is a little bit
of a silly example but think about the
supervillains right they always got to
reveal their plan to the hero which
usually results in the plan being foiled
why the hell do they do that because
they want to have somebody who they can
convey their information about how
they're gonna blow up the world because
they want to share it with someone right
cicero's not talking about that
specifically what he is talking about
something quite similar so they still
want some some other people the last
thing that he says has to do with
solitude its solitude something that we
really really want he says well yes and
no so he goes on and says imagine that a
god would remove us from these haunts of
human beings and put us in some solitary
place and while providing us there and
plenteous abundance with all material
things for which our nature yearns
should take from us altogether the power
to gaze upon our fellow men this is an
interesting thought experience
experiment so imagine that I know some
some super powerful alien or a god or
whatever you want it to be would put you
in some place and you've got everything
that you could possibly want but no
human beings would you be happy a lot of
people say oh yeah I love it I can't
wait to get away from all these sob z'
well then you ship Rackham and it turns
out that they're not quite so happy with
it he says who would be such a man of
iron as to be able to endure that sort
of life who is there from whom solitude
would not snatch the enjoyment of every
pleasure this is an interesting point
that he's making we enjoy our pleasures
more when there's the possibility of
sharing them with other people even if
we're doing it alone right
the proverbial drinker who drinks alone
that's enjoying something on your own
right
but they might enjoy actually doing it
with other people then they talk with
other people about their scotch that
they enjoy or the drinks they're mixing
or things like that you take that away
from them and it becomes a you know a
pure object relation to that particular
intoxicant
he has another interesting thing that he
says here as well he talks about this
saying of our ketosis of Tarentum so he
says if a man should ascend alone into
heaven and behold clearly the structure
of the universe and the beauty of the
Stars there would be no pleasure for him
in the on spiring sight which would have
filled in with the light if he had
someone to whom he could describe what
he had seen
now we could imagine there might be some
people who actually be totally cool with
that right but there's a lot of us who
wouldn't and I think Cicero is really
onto something we we shouldn't deprive
ourselves of friendship solely to try to
free ourselves of cares and worries
maybe we should take on those cares and
worries so that we can enjoy the greater
fret the greater enjoyment and the
greater we might say moral status of
being the kehna person who has friends
and shares things within friendships
you